alright Brandon Brandon where'd you grow
up where you from hum I grew up in Los
Angeles California I was born in 1988
January 16 I'm a native from La of there
all of my life okay and tell me about
your your childhood you had both your
parents growing up um no I didn't have
both of my parents I kind of had like a
village of basically of women women
basically my grandmother my mom and my
aunt who passed away from cancer so I
said was the other questions fire no so
she lost your mom no I lost my end to
cancer but my mom wasn't fully in my
life she had me at 19 so she you know
she was raised in church so they my mom
hid her pregnancy and basically I don't
like her miracle baby I'm her only child
okay so I kind of have the choice if I
wanted to live with my grandmother but I
didn't have a choice because my mother
wasn't always stable because she tried
but it was always a fight like okay this
is my child when it came to Mike my Aunt
Shirley my own grandmother and my mom so
they kind of all three of those women
spoiled me and made this Munster out of
me so tell me about your childhood David
my childhood um tell me that it was okay
it wasn't the best let's just say it was
okay outside but in the inside it wasn't
the best because I never had my own room
and that's something that a child in LA
and a suburban area would have I've
always lived like an a a good area I
guess you could say in West LA but I
didn't have like okay this is your room
because you know I didn't have both
parents I didn't mean my dad into the
agent
20
1:22 because he was actually sent to the
UM to the Marines because of the fact he
was I guess popular but I believe he
might have been a gang banger ok so my
my grandmother which is his mom
well I didn't know sent him off to the
Marines and I didn't meet him until I
was 21
yeah and what can't get me you in high
school
I'm saying again what kind of kid were
you in high school I was well I was
active I went to helmets in high school
I am was in the dance program the little
sports I was in a music academy program
it was a performing arts school yeah
performing the art school I was pretty
popular but I didn't always fit in like
ninth grade I didn't they'd always was
talking about the shame of my head I
didn't have the best looks so I had to
basically kind of compensate and I was
draining my aunt my mom and she tried
her best because you know she's a single
parent and she's kind of had a life like
me like she's always pushed but she was
pushed you know back trying to do other
things and sometimes that's life but
that's neither here there any any crazy
events happen in high school Oh in high
school the craziest event would be I
guess me being diagnosed with HIV at 17
okay I met a guy online this is the
summer right before going back to school
in my senior year so I am I went to a
guy's house who I was talking to on the
cell phone you know they had cell phones
and basically I ended up meeting him the
night of my best friend's party
she turned 17 it was in August I went to
his house after I mean I watch his house
after the party
and after that we had sex which I've
never had annoying 2/4 sorry was a guy
before and it was a gang banger so that
was kind of like a rough kind of like oh
that's a fantasy I guess but I didn't
think we were gonna have sex like that
so I kind of had no choice because I was
dropped off so me being under you know
seventeen it was like 2:00 in the
morning hi
but he was forceful basically and I
can't say I was raped but it was like
okay once it began it just didn't end
until he finished and then we went to
sleep and he kicked me off and he kicked
me out in the morning then I caught the
bus back home and then after that
probably a month later I was really sick
I my aunt went and got me Kentucky Fried
Chicken and it was August and then yeah
September in September I started getting
really sick I believe so and the way it
happened was just really weird if I got
the flu so I was losing so much weight
losing all this blood and then to kind
of fast forward homecoming comes home
come you know homecoming dance and all
that and respected I would always show
up you know fashionably fashionably late
but I want to see what I had only I
couldn't fit any clothing I was sick I
could barely make it there I probably
two weeks after that school is starting
or school has started which is in
October and I want a Saturday morning
well before that I actually was
diagnosed they did three tests this is
two weeks be prior before going to the
hospital I am basically
you know would to the pediatrician you
know you have a pediatrician into the
age of 18 a kaiser my doctor asked me
like how are you have you been sexually
active I'm thinking okay have you
followed me because I wasn't sexually
active really you know as far as
intercourse and he they took a test and
then I took another test but then I came
back again he took his test he said I
think you may be hiv-positive and I'm
like what
so he said what we're gonna take another
chance so the last the time after that I
brought my grandmother and my mom with
me I left them in the lobby cuz I didn't
know what I was gonna find out and I was
really sick and we're still losing
weight and then they told me the my
doctor told me and I said okay what
should i do should I tell my mom and I
was kind of crying he said I'll go out
to the lobby with you and my mom she's
already dramatic she um my grandmother
was there too and of course because
something like that my grandmother
always like she could take care of
everyone when they're sick so I am
basically what's the lobby and the
doctor wouldn't with me it's home I'm on
and my mom was on the ground crying
because I'm her only child and on top of
that she probably felt like she failed
as a parent
because my my grandmother was so hard on
her and it was like okay I had to keep
my grandmother happy because I'm getting
all these material things from my aunt
and my mom didn't feel I don't hate I
always felt like my mom wasn't good
enough because she didn't give me what I
want and I know good people make
mistakes and my mom tried her hardest
it's very positive
okay it was apparent I mean I really
know okay I've said that educational
ping HIV+ notice Tom's gonna die
they had his talk on that same day they
had his talk today it was like an
out-of-body experience so I was just
like numb they had the doctor talk yeah
we went met all the like that's against
the person view sorry you miss the
psychologist or that day no we met
another doctor and then we met another
doctor which I they began to become my
family because like they kept you know
they took me in because I'm young and um
and I couldn't and I'm kind of sad
because I want to still keep going there
but I couldn't because of the fact that
I didn't have the proper insurance so I
you know how Kaiser kicked me out and I
you know went to where everyone else
goes and that was the best place for me
but to revert back two weeks later I'm
still losing I'm in high school I'm
still losing all this blood and it was
just like oh my god I couldn't basically
stand so um I was missing school who
wants to miss you know your senior year
that's the year that you can do
everything I barely even I don't even
think I did my dance so I didn't dance
show because every year would be a day I
was in a dance program but I barely was
able to do it I was so sick the two
weeks my best friend was going to
Atlanta and my mom happy to see them and
she was crying I was crying that morning
he was on Saturday morning I fainted and
my my aunt
and my grandmother because you know
there I went to school was closer and of
course my mom still trying her hardest a
Saturday I'm sorry that Saturday I
passed out and I'll pass out on a puddle
of blood and after that that room are
you bleeding from um I had infections
they said I had ulcers and I guess my
mean sister was so low I guess my body
was just prone to infections in there I
started just losing all of this blood
maybe losing blood where I was throwing
up both ways in and out you know and in
the when a blood became a certain colors
like okay I don't know what I should do
so that's why I had no choice but to go
be rushed to the hospital they came and
got me I went to Kaiser and I was in the
hospital for a whole month basically I
had thirteen blood transfusions and I
guess it got better you're still here
yeah I'm 30 now I was diagnosed 2005
yeah 2005 high school and I'm here now
so you're not the main event but I
graduated you made a lot of advancements
yeah yeah so you feel lucky to be alive
right huh you must be feel lucky to be
alive
I'm even lucky I feel like
I feel like it's kind of part of my life
now so I was like okay yeah and you
still have to take medication you know
you go in and out of things and then
things happen and I'm here and so what
are you doing today with your life what
am i doing now yeah pretty live I'm
homeless
you're here on Skid Row I guess
everywhere damage how does almost
considered Skid Row but I did I'd come
and eat at the mission you live in a
chat no I'm more of a trained sleeper I
like to be on the train I don't feel
safe down here I'd get bullied yeah I
don't really fit in down here dude
you're right you're ready to train all
night yeah yeah which that is good that
they actually keep the train running for
homeless people but yeah I am I came
back out here because of this fact that
I lost my place and I was so happy to
have a place because you know a lot to
happen after losing my hand but that's
neither here there but I'm homeless and
I don't live in a tent I don't really
like tents I like to be indoors with you
know a wall on the door and all that and
I don't want to give too complacent with
that but and do you use any drugs that
are on the street yeah I do
which ones ee crystal meth yeah I do but
I guess you can say I was doing that
before it didn't have anything to do
with me actually coming back to skid row
but I've been doing crystal meth because
I consider myself not gay but I I have
intercourse with males
so that was you know that was a gauge
where I get first and then it hit here
and now it's really an epidemic but yeah
I am currently doing crystal meth
and we have any plans I mean but you're
kind of stuck here on Skid Row doing
drugs it's not the most plans and world
my plan fell through I had a place and
it's almost it hasn't even been a year
yet but I got a place of DMH and I have
to relinquish my unit because I was
being bullied I'm being bullied again so
I'm used to being bully because right
before coming to the Roselyn or what
have you of DMH I was at a transitional
home I was bullied there by all the men
I mean they were taking my clothes I
mean I was calling my mom maybe just
saying there this is happening that's
happening I was just always everywhere
that I go I'm always kind of by myself
even if I'm popular but people won't
like me for no reason so I think I'm
just expected for that set I expect that
to happen now but it's really gotten
physical like me getting hit
I got hit I've been hitting the train
for no reason I've had a knife put out
on me for no reason I'm sleep I wake up
a guy has a knife because he's tweaking
I am no actually he sucked me my and you
know your sleep whoo that's almost like
okay did I get sucked out of life it
feels weird I didn't know what happened
then the other weapon which was a knife
out of I don't know why I'm going that
it seems like I'm the only one downtown
that gets bullied as much you know I can
be with other people and they won't say
anything for them but they will say that
something to me but I guess is that's
what happens so I'm here now and it's
not that bad it's this Turner on me this
come around where I guess this second
time being homeless I don't find clothes
and things like that I've always been
into closing things but it's not that
bad now I know how to handle it and I
have this puppy show puppies on a leash
now so yeah
yeah I'm good all right well Brandon
thank you thank you turn your story and
good luck with where you go from here
thank you
all right thank you
you